werden wir menschen ferngesteuert werden
wir schon jetzt von unseren regierung
bewusst mit wissenschaftlicher hilfe
manipuliert mehr dazu bei pixum science
fiction daten sind inzwischen zu einer
währung geworben facebook google sie
alle leben von daten einfaches beispiel
trekking im internet ihr sucht nach
neuen sport schuhen entscheidet euch
dann aber doch dagegen klickt er eine
sekunde später auf irgend eine webseite
und schon seht ihr werbung
wahrscheinlich sogar für genau diese
sportschuhe
ja die folge manche klicken dann noch
mal zurück zu den schuhen und legen
sehen den warenkorb und drei tage später
landen sie vor der haustüre
das ist noch ganz simpel aber daten
lenken uns immer mehr zur entscheidung
die wir vielleicht ohne diese aktive
lenkung getroffen hätten
ähnliches hat jetzt die bundesregierung
vor
die technik die unserer bundesregierung
nutzen will heissen touch zu deutsch
anstoßen na jin wurde von den
wissenschaftlern cars sandstein und
richard taylor entwickelt und 2003 im
fachmagazin american economic review
vorgestellt mittlerweile haben sie zweit
gebracht von studienautoren in einer
fachzeitschrift zu beratern des
amerikanischen präsidenten barack obama
was aber kann diese technik touching ist
sozusagen ein gegenmodell der
klassischen verboten bzw der gesetzen
normen im sinne des nachos heißt es
nicht du darfst nicht rauchen
es heißt vielmehr wenn du nicht raus
dann bekommst du xy so eine belohnung
zum beispiel oder man wird in irgendeine
richtung gedrängt na jin ist also kein
strenges regelwerk managing möchte man
unerwünschtes verhalten durch positive
belohnung oder ähnliches vermeiden in
der psychologie spricht man auch von
einer konditionierung beispiele sind
drucker die standardmäßig papier
beidseitig bedrucken wenn man zu
einseitig besuchen will muss man das
manuell einstellen die bessere
präsentation von obst als süßigkeiten in
kantinen da werden dann mehr wird dann
mehr obst gekauft die berühmte fliege in
den originalen die die männer dazu
bewegt besser zu treffen im kleinen
rahmen beispielsweise im kreise der
familie ist das ja ganz okay aber wie
sieht das aus wenn unsere regierung das
mit uns betreibt darf die regierung ihre
bürger mit psychologischer raffinesse
lenken
ob sie es darf bzw ob es moralisch
vertretbar ist scheint unsere regierung
noch etwas lose im raum stehen zu lassen
anfang diesen jahres holte sich unsere
kanzlerin cars sandstein ins haus er
sollte ihr einen kleinen crashkurs zum
thema najin geben werden wir also schon
jetzt gesteuert oder ist das wieder nur
panikmache zitat das matching ist in
jedem supermarkt an jeder tankstelle
schon längst alltag und zwar um produkte
zu verkaufen
darüber klärt keiner auf so die
medizinethikerin alena tricks wenn man
sich aber mal vorstellt wie weit die
anwendungsbereiche für eine regierung
reichen könnten
da kommt man schon etwas ins grübeln es
reicht weit über das was im supermarkt
passiert hinaus könnte uns der
psychologische stoß die zuhörer anstoß
nicht auch in die falsche richtung
stupsen psychologische tricks im
unterbewusstsein können ja richtig
gefährlich weisen bzw
werden dann gefährlich wenn die
konditionierung also das
belohnungssystem auf unlautere ziele
hinaus führt bzw zum erreichen dieser
unlauteren ziele ja stichwort
manipulation
wie sehen sks sandstein und roger taylor
zitat paternalismus ist deshalb wichtig
weil es unserer überzeugung nach für
entscheidungs architekten legitim ist
das verhalten der menschen zu
beeinflussen um ihr leben länger
gesünder und besser zu machen anders
gesagt wir sind dafür dass private
institutionen behörden und regierungen
und muss versuchen die entscheidung der
menschen so zu lenken dass sie hinterher
besser dastehen und zwar gemessen an
ihren eigenen maßstäben so beschreiben
die beiden ihre technik in ihrem buch
wie man kluge entscheidungen anstoß
paternalismus steht für eine väterliche
bevormundung najin kann also der
gemeinschaft dem staat und bürgern
tatsächlich nutzen noch mal zurück zum
beispiel mit den sportschulen solange
wir das mit uns machen lassen wird es
mit uns gemacht europa und amerika
versuchen derzeit auch mit uns etwas zu
machen was nicht alle so besonders toll
finden
mehr dazu erfahrt ihr im video hier oben
geht tipp da geht es über das i und
lasst uns doch meinen kommentaren eure
meinung zum thema najem wissen was sagt
ihr dazu was ist eure meinung sollte
eine regierung so eine technik nutzen um
gutes zu erreichen oder nicht also bis
dann bleibt dran